you can cry on command yes really
I didn't I okay that's not something you
can how long do you need to prepare for
that I mean I think if we just like keep
talking and I don't know okay some point
I really drink some water so that I'm
hydrated okay I just keep talking to you
you're going to start crying at some
point okay I tried to be up to be
talking about things that are related to
Jurassic world or just that in general
okay just be small talk it doesn't
matter you know what I like about Home
Depot is your duct tape all kinds of
duct tape you can get gray duct tape
yeah get black yeah oh is huge right
gone to Home Depot many times and I've
bought all kinds of things I bought
styrofoam
I've bought things that I could use to
tape other things together two other
things I bought piping I really like
buying nails and wood I like buying was
just wandering the aisles sometimes
buying all kinds of things at Home Depot
sometimes I'm there for days I stay at a
Home Depot for days and days and days
and days
and I just stay there and sometimes I
just wander the aisles all by myself at
Home Depot and I think about all the
amazing
and I think about all the incredible
products they have and I think about
everything that they have at Home Depot
and I just think to myself my god Home
Depot how do you do this how do you do
this incredible thing you give so much
and you get so little in return I mean
they really paying you enough for what
it's worth they're not really paying you
and I think that at some point people
should actually give Home Depot what
they're do because it's not fair
it's a company it's in a company that
should be
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
my god it built so real early
I think our producer was crying because
I think lo this is the sponsor yeah if
it loads a need a sponsor
okay well then alright well
it was a comedy bit Lowe's doesn't make
us cry yeah there were so yes you just
yeah boo yeah
hey thank you you just say that's their
new slogan Lowe's it won't make you cry